since I reverted to Islam my love and
understanding of Jesus became so much
stronger all right let's
[Music]
cook because the Quran explains Jesus in
such a clear and succinct way is that so
I mean when I read the Quran I didn't
get that impression that the Quran was
clear and succinct about its christology
I mean in one place it says in 4171 that
Jesus is the word of Allah that was sent
down to Mary and a spirit from him but
in other places it says that Jesus is no
more than a messenger so is he no more
than a messenger or is he more than a
messenger and even Allah's word I don't
know I guess it's not that clear and
succinct is it but what shocked me is
the fact that Jesus is described in the
Quran in a way that's also supported in
the
Bible I can't wait to see this one and
it's supported with multiple verses
clear verses simple verses verses that
don't even need
interpretation or even context in Islam
our understanding of Jesus is very
simple he's a prophet he's a messenger
of God he was born of the Virgin Mary
he's the Messiah he performed Miracles
with the permission of God
did you guys hear all that he's the
messenger of Allah he's a prophet of
Allah he's the Messiah he's a miracle
worker by the permission of Allah but
your Quran says that he's no more than a
messenger oh but by the way he also
forgot he's the word of Allah and a
spirit from Allah don't forget those
titles for some reason he left those out
but Jesus has all of these titles
applicable to him and yet the Quran is
supposed to be clear that he's no he's
just a messenger just a human here's
another thing my friend can you tell me
what Messiah means since the Quran
explains Jesus in a very simple and
concise and succinct way can you show me
a verse in the Quran that breaks down
what the Messiah is what it means to be
the Messiah and why Jesus is the Messiah
and no one else can does the Quran
explain that it absolutely does
unless you want to be like one of my
friends who says that you know all the
messengers are Messiahs but you don't
want to make that mistake but why do we
give the Quran Authority why do we even
accept the Quran as the truth I don't
know why you give the Quran Authority
because the Quran itself doesn't give
itself authority over the previous
scriptures in chapter 10:94 it says if
you are in doubt about what has been
revealed to you from your lord go and
ask those who read read the book before
you you're supposed to come to us the
Jews and the Christians and come to our
Bible to substantiate what you have in
your Quran not the other way around
chapter 16 verse 43 talk un to Muhammad
Allah says if you do not know go and ask
the people of the reminder it calls us
the people of the reminder our book is
the reminder so to validate your Quran
it needs to line up with our scriptures
according to your Quran so I don't know
why you give the Quran Authority when
your Quran doesn't do that fact that
there's no errors there's no mistakes
there's nothing that can't be explained
with the most basic level of logic in
chapter 5: 116 to 117 of the Quran Jesus
will respond I only told them what you
commanded me to that you shall worship
God my Lord and your Lord but it aligns
perfectly with a verse in the Bible John
2017 which is when Jesus himself said I
am ascending to my father and your
father to my God and your
God that's the verse he says that it
perfectly aligns with this should get
good this this is getting good this is
getting good the first is the fact that
Jesus said my father and your father
whose father my father and whose father
and your father there's a father Jesus
has a
father this immediately debunks the idea
that Jesus is the literal Son of God
because he said and your father which
would imply that we are all the literal
Sons and Daughters of God which
obviously isn't the case let me show you
guys how silly this argument is imagine
we have a father who has a literal son
born to him by his wife and then the
couple also goes out and adopts a son
adopts a child and so now he has a
literal son and he has a an adopted son
so if the brother if the begotten son
let's say told the adopted son I'm going
to my father and your father does that
now mean that they are the son of their
father in the same sense that they have
the same exact type of sunship and
relationship no that doesn't change the
fact that he's the literal son while
they while his brother is an adopted son
they both share the same father they
just are sons in different senses
similarly Jesus is the begotten son of
the father while the Believers are the
adopted Sons and Daughters of the father
such a silly argument the second is the
fact that Jesus said my God and your God
so he's referring to the father as our
God and His God as well same mistake
being made here the father is not the
god of Jesus in the same sense that he's
the god of us the father is the source
of our creation we began to exist and he
is our creator so he is our God in that
way however Jesus shares the same Divine
Essence as the father he is the second
person of the godhead the second person
of the Trinity and the Bible says that
in Jeremiah
32:27 that God is the God of All Flesh
so what does this mean this means that
Jesus who shares the same Divine Essence
as the father also took on flesh the
word became flesh and dwelt amongst us
so once Jesus Took on flesh the father
became his God pertaining to his
Humanity this is also displayed in Psalm
22 David speaking prophetically of the
Messiah says from my mother's womb you
have been my God so there's a point in
time where Jesus existed prior to his
Humanity where he then takes on humanity
and the father becomes his God in that
relationship so it's not that the father
is a separate God than Jesus or Jesus is
Lesser God than the father know is that
they have the same Essence they have the
same divine nature but when it comes to
Jesus's human nature pertaining to his
human nature the father is his God the
god of his flesh if you study the Bible
a little bit more you wouldn't make
these little mistakes here and the last
thing is the fact that he said I am
Ascend in to my father and your father
to my God and your God which correlates
perfectly with what's said in the Quran
so you mean to tell me that where when
Jesus says he is a sending to his father
and your father that that aligns
perfectly with the Quran can you I I
would like for any Muslim and for the
Muslims watching this I I challenge you
show me a single verse in the entire
Quran I'll say my Shahar show me a
single verse in the entire Quran where
it says that Allah is the father of
Jesus or where it says that Allah is
your father or where it says that Allah
is a father at all show me one
unequivocal verse one unambiguous
statement where Allah himself subh Allah
says I am a father such a definitive
verse it's clear a 5-year-old can read
this and understand it I agree a
5-year-old can read this verse in the
Bible and read your verse in the Quran
and see how the Quran explicitly goes
against this Bible verse and how the
words of Jesus deem Muhammad as a false
prophet the a false book and Allah a
false god man I should I should give you
the chef hat man hey hey Cornell cor hey
man go take take take my chef hat man
here here it's yours man you cooking
Islam right now boy go ahead take it in
John 173 Jesus refers to the father as
the only true God he doesn't say I'm the
only true God or we are the only true
God but the father is the only true God
the who is the only true God but the
father is the only true God wait wait
wait wait wait I didn't hear it who is
the only true God the father is the only
true God wait wait wait Cornell for
those who circling the stone in the back
they can't hear you man who did you say
is the only true God the father is the
only true God well if the father is the
only true God and Allah's not a father
then that would mean that Allah is a
false god correct mean that makes sense
to me even a 5-year-old can come to that
conclusion in John
10:29 he refers to the father as greater
than all he doesn't say we are greater
than all or I am greater than all but
the father is greater than all right
here we jump over to John 10 let's start
at verse 27 he says my sheep hear my
voice and I know them and they follow me
I give them eternal life
uhoh they will never perish and no one
will snatch them out of my hand my
father who has given them to me is
greater than all and no one is able to
snatch them out of my father's hand I
and the father are one so here we have
Jesus saying that the Sheep belong to
him they hear his voice what which are
which are callbacks to the Old Testament
where Yahweh says that the Sheep are the
Sheep of his hand and the Sheep listen
to his voice to yahweh's voice Jesus is
claiming to be Yahweh here and here we
have him saying that I give them eternal
life well I know that only God is the
one who gives eternal life especially to
the Muslim here so here we have Jesus
equating himself with God then he says
that the father who's given to them to
me is greater than all I and the father
are one so if the father is greater than
all then so is Jesus is greater than all
since he and the father is one and how
do we know this that it's not just some
generic context in which uh you know
it's one in unity or one in purpose like
how the disciples can be one in the Lord
how Believers can be one with Jesus in
the father no because the context is
that he has the same attributes as the
father see here in Deuteronomy
32:39 it says see now that I even I am
he I kill and I make alive I wound and I
heal and there is none that can do
deliver out of my hand that's what Jesus
just said he says I give eternal life
and none can snatch them out of my hand
none can also snatch out of the father's
hands why because they're one in essence
they are one they have the same nature
not simply that they are just one in
purpose but they are one in essence none
can they are the one who give life the
father and the son are the one who give
life and they are the one who none can
snatch out of their hand here we go
again with Psalm 95:7 it says this for
he is our God now listen to this and we
are the people of his pasture and the
Sheep of his hand today if you hear his
voice so whose voice does the sheep hear
God's voice whose hand are the sheep in
God's hand so we are in God's hand we
hear God's voice we belong to him as his
sheep and Jesus said
my sheep hear my voice I know them and
they follow me I give them eternal life
they are the Sheep of my hand none can
snatch them out of my hand Jesus is
claiming to be God so here in this
context Jesus is showing that he shares
the same divine nature with the father
he's one in essence with the father not
just one in purpose in Mark
13:32 Jesus actually prostrates and
praise to the father it's actually mark
14:35 5 and 36 where Jesus goes and
prostrates to his father and he prays uh
but you know the slip of the tongue we
all make mistakes no one's perfect so
I'll let you slide with that one he
prays like a Muslim does and he submits
to God's will so if Jesus praying to the
father prostrating to the father is
praying just like a Muslim please repeat
after me say I pray and worship the
Father the heavenly father is my father
who I love adore believe in and I pray
to and I want you to prostrate I want
you to prostrate fall on your face and
pray to your father pra say father help
me Father Glory Be Your Name father I
thank you since you pray Like Jesus Does
since that's how Muslim prays in Matthew
4:10 Jesus tells Satan to worship God he
doesn't say worship me he doesn't say
worship us he says worship God because
Jesus is God that would make him worthy
of worship right he doesn't say don't
worship me he doesn't say I'm not God I
mean the man these these arguments are
not good man um this this is we got to
do better hopefully he does better in
this video in Luke 18:19 Jesus refuses
to be called good because his rebuttal
is only God Alone is good Jesus does not
refuse to be called good going back to
John chapter 10 Jesus says right here in
verse 14 he says I am the Good Shepherd
he does not refuse to call himself good
he claims to be good what are you
talking about what he does is is he asks
the Young Ruler why do you call me good
that's not a denial of being good it's a
thought-provoking question just like
earlier when you quoted in your video
you quoted uh Surah five where Allah
asks Jesus did you tell these people to
worship yourself as Gods besides me does
that that is that is Allah literally
ignorant on whether Jesus said that to
people or not or is he asking him the
question to make a point you see that so
that's not Jesus denying to be good he
asked the Young Ruler why do you call me
good because Jesus is good in every way
and if Jesus is good then the Young
Ruler would recognize that he is God and
he wasn't ready for that Jesus did this
all the time and Mark
6:4 Jesus refers to himself as a prophet
because the people in his hometown
doubted him they questioned how he
suddenly became so wise how he suddenly
was able to perform Miracles but Jesus's
response was simple a prophet is not
without honor except in their Hometown
among their relatives and in their
household it amazes me sometimes it
doesn't surprise me but it does amaze me
uh you know sometimes I I wonder like
all I wonder
about the intellect of the Muslims and
how they argue um because it's it's
almost as if they argue purposely not
knowing what Christians believe as if we
believe that Jesus is merely a prophet
or merely a human notice Jesus in the
verse doesn't say that he's only a
prophet uh neither does he say I am a
Prophet by the way he doesn't say I am a
prophet in that verse so but you have to
glean that from the context you know
ironically enough but but here we have
Jesus who is God In the Flesh so yes
he's God and he's a prophet matter of
fact God himself refers to himself as a
messenger see here in Malachi 3 God says
see I am going to send my messenger and
he will clear the way before me so God
says he's going to send his messenger
and he will clear the way before me this
is the messenger in the wilderness John
the Baptist who will clear the way for
the Lord for God himself so God is
coming and he says then the Lord you
seek will suddenly come to his Temple
the messenger of the Covenant you desire
see he is coming so the one who's coming
owns the temple the temple belongs to
him that's God himself and he's coming
and he calls himself the messenger of
the
Covenant and who better to represent God
to rightly communicate the message of
God than God
himself so of course God himself comes
and he is the prophet the prophet he is
the messenger so Jesus is not just
merely a prophet but he is God himself
the messenger of the Covenant so Jesus's
response is simple I'm a prophet notice
how he had to interpret that but that's
not what Jesus says he doesn't say I am
am a prophet but he had to interpret
that get the context clues to understand
that Jesus is claiming to be a prophet
and Prophets are not accepted in in
their Hometown pay attention to his
hypocrisy later on he said earlier that
these verses don't need to be
interpreted they don't need to be extra
uh explained but they're pretty clear
precise don't need to interpret it
verbatim it's
explicit but he just had to interpret
that now let's see if he's that
courteous with other things why then are
we referring to him as God when he never
ever in the Bible explicitly said in his
own words that he is God there's not a
single direct verse
see now let just to be tell y'all
something man I am not a prophet but I
told y'all with the verse that he read
and where Jesus says that a prophet is
not accepted in his own in his home Town
Jesus does not directly say I am a
prophet yet this guy takes that verse
and understands that Jesus is claiming
to be a prophet or that Jesus says that
he's a prophet but then he says well we
have no verse where Jesus himself says
explicitly the words I am
God you see how hypocritical these guys
are because it's it's not for truth it's
not for honesty and intellectual
Integrity it's because he's a Muslim and
he has a narrative Jesus can't be God so
therefore even a book that I call
corrupted I cannot admit that it calls
him God but let's see where Jesus does
explicitly call himself God even
according to quranic standards for
example we have Revelation 1:1 17 where
it where John says this when I saw him
Jesus I fell at his feet like a dead man
he laid his right hand on me and said
don't be afraid I am the first and the
last well over here in the Quran we have
chapter 57:3 who's the first and the
last it says he is the first and the
last and the outward and the inward he
is noer of all things this is talking
about Allah here so Allah is the first
and the last Jesus claims to be the
first and the last therefore Jesus is
even God according to Muslim
standards now my question is this if
there's no explicit verse where Jesus
claims to be God then why in the world
is Allah stealing titles from Jesus this
isn't the only place watch this cuz this
is going to be brought up to later a lot
of Christians tend to follow implicit
verses which are more ambiguous verses
verses that actually do need
interpretations over the explicit verses
which which are direct like all the ones
that I mentioned notice how he says that
he brought up explicit verses while
Christians rely on implicit verses but
stop me if you guys heard any verse that
he brought
up quote the words where Jesus says I am
not God
explicitly in those words where he
explicitly says he is not
God I don't hear any I didn't see any
and see any verse where Jesus says I am
not God but what he's doing is is he's
going to verses that he believes implies
that Jesus is not God here we are again
with the double standard and the
hypocrisy Christians will tend to follow
verses like I am the way and the truth
and the life no one comes through the
father except through me H I wonder why
you know what this actually brings to my
to my mind another way that this verse
right here proves that Jesus is God
According to Islamic standards let's go
again shall we yes here we go John 14:6
Jesus told him I am the way the truth
and the life no one comes to the father
except through me now when we look over
here at the Quran in chapter 22:6 it
says that is because Allah he is the
truth and it is he who gives life to the
Dead and it is he who is able to do all
things isn't that amazing that here we
have again Allah stealing another title
from Jesus so if Allah is the truth and
Jesus is the truth then who does that
make
Jesus means that Jesus is claiming to be
God here isn't it it means that he's God
according to your Islamic standards but
let me show you how this actually works
against Allah notice how you see how
Jesus says he is the way he says I am
the way he's not on the way he's not on
the path but he is the path he is the
way now watch here what the Quran says
about Allah look at chapter 11:56 it
says lo I have put my trust in Allah my
Lord and your lord not an animal but he
doth grasp it by it by the for loock lo
my Lord is on a straight path
wait a second Allah is on the straight
path I thought he would be the straight
path no Jesus is the way he is the
straight path while your lord Allah is
on the straight path I wonder who he's
on the on the straight path to who is he
on his way to to Jesus he better hope so
I would rather put my trust in the Lord
who is the straight path who is the way
instead of the false Lord who needs to
be on the straight path word the father
and I are
one these actually do need
interpretation because what does we are
one even mean when we get married to our
spouse we become one with our spouse so
that meant to be taken literally or is
it meant to be taken figuratively now I
already dealt with that earlier but I
just found what he said here interesting
that he's questioning what does we are
one even mean that being one can be
interpreted differently that it's not
really explicit or clear what one being
one means I find that interesting
because when we go to the Quran it says
in the Quran this say he is Allah the
one the one what what does one even mean
this is muslim's favorite verse to go to
but even this has to be interpreted what
does one even mean you got to explain
that is he the one God is he one person
is he one of many
things who knows Allah so what that says
is that we are supposed to take the
explicit verses the direct verses
because those are the foundation of the
book I agree let's take the explicit
verses shall we Isaiah 9:6 it says for a
child will be born to us a son will be
given to us and the government will be
upon his shoulders and he will be named
wonderful
counselor Mighty God Eternal Father
Prince of Peace pretty explicit to me
John chapter 1 verse one in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was
God all things were created through him
and apart from him from him not one
thing was created that has been created
uhoh pretty explicit to me the word
became flesh and took up residence among
us we observed his glory the glory as
the one and only son from the father
full of grace and truth pretty explicit
John chapter 14:9 Jesus said to him have
I been among you all this time without
your knowing me Phillip the one who has
seen me has seen the father how can you
say show us the father if you seen me
you've seen the father pretty explicit
to me Titus 213
while we wait for the Blessed hope and
appearing of the glory of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ pretty explicit
to me Romans 9:5 the ancestors are
theirs and from them by physical descent
came the Messiah who is God over all
praised forever amen pretty explicit to
me
Colossians chapter 2:9 for the entire
fullness of God's nature dwells bodily
in
Christ fully God fully human pretty
explicit to me first John 5:20 and we
know that the Son of God has come and
given us understanding that we may know
the true one we are in the true one that
is in his son Jes Jesus Christ he is the
true God and eternal life pretty
explicit to me let's do one more
Revelation
2213 I am the Alpha and the Omega the
first and the last the beginning and the
end sounds pretty explicit to me and
there's so much more but we have all of
these explicit verses not just from the
words of Jesus from the mouth of Jesus
but also from his Apostles saying
directly that Jesus is
God there's no doubt about it there's no
confusion about it it's right there in
your face and if it was a snake it would
have bit
you so what what what what we what what
we doing here man what we talking about
here man oh my godic
[Music]